hello and welcome to fandango's weekend
ticket I'm Dan Perrault and there are
three movies opening up this weekend the
drama 13 hours the secret soldiers of
Benghazi the animated film norm of the
north and the comedy ride-along - let's
see which one's perfect for you
first up 13 hours the secret soldiers of
Benghazi this is a Michael Bay directed
action film based on the true story of
six members of a US security team who
defended an American compound in 2012 I
was blown away by John Krasinski's
performance and blown away by the things
that blow up if you like action
thrillers based on true stories like
zero dark thirty this would be a great
pick next up is norm of the north this
animated film follows a loveable polar
bear named norm who sees the world a
little differently than the rest as he
travels to the big city to save his
Arctic home with lots of quirky
characters and fun moments this is
perfect for families and finally right
along to this sequel brings back the
unlikely cop duo of Kevin Hart and ice
cube and I like the addition of Ken Jong
Olivia Munn and Tyrese Gibson who joined
the team to help take down a powerful
drug lord in Miami this would be a great
pick for you if you like action comedy
and that classic ice cube face fandango
correspondent Alicia Malone had a chance
to catch up with Kevin Hart and ice cube
stars are right along - lets check it
out I love the combination of the two
characters and this kind of you know
straight man wiseguy buddy cop comedy
has been around for a long time why do
you think it works so well I think as
audience members you identify with one
of the guys you're either a straight
person with a crazy friend or you're the
crazy friend you know who's you know
people got to try to keep in line it's
also interesting to see how the events
of the first term affected both of the
characters particularly Ben he now has a
bit of like I sold the case last time I
can't do it again
you know those Ben's the guy that went
to Vegas and won and won money his first
time game
he wants to go back every time you don't
know how to do it let me do it I'm gonna
win like he's that guy and we've all met
that guy before and I love that you see
you see James slowly start to come
around and acknowledge that in this one
you know what our movie was so special
about it is we got an action comedy
mixed into a romantic comedy yeah you
know it's a perfect blend and that's why
I think audiences really love right now
let's see what you the Fandango fans are
buzzing about on this week's fantasy
patient here are the scores so that's
what's going on this week at the movies
I'm Dan Perrault and I'll see you next
time be sure to download the Fandango
app for the latest movies showtimes an
exclusive Fandango content at your
fingertips so what's your weekend ticket
going to be buy your tickets on Fandango